c'est là c'est là c'est là salut
dans les années 90
je jouais dans un café théâtre rue
Fontaine qui s'appelait le carré blanc
avec mes potes
les nous c'est nous
Bruno Salomone Éric Collado Eric Masson
manuclat
et puis un soir il y a un type qui est
arrivé
qui nous a regardé qui s'est marré
qui est venu nous voir à la fin du
spectacle et qui nous a dit
[Musique]
je vous aime bien vous m'avez fait
marrer
vous avez l'air de bien vous aimer j'ai
une émission l'année prochaine qui
s'appelle fiesta je voudrais vous
engager
et bien ce type c'était Patrick
Sébastien
ce type c'était un prince qui a un peu
changé notre destin
il y a rien que pour ça j'aurai j'aurais
te remercier encore toujours et je
t'aime
Jean Dujardin j'embrasse fort elle s'en
fiche
[Applaudissements]
bien mais d'ailleurs tous ceux que j'ai
aidés ils sont tous reconnaissés mais
c'est vrai que c'est tu te dis que tout
est possible parce que quand je les ai
pris il faisait des sketchs je sais pas
si c'est des seaux d'eau tu vois et un
soir j'étais chez moi je te dois ma télé
et je le vois monter aux Oscars recevoir
un Oscar j'ai dit mais ça veut dire tout
est possible
Jean Dujardin bravo
ce qui est arrivé les gens aujourd'hui
jardin c'était à l'âge de 24 ans c'était
pas dans fiesta mais c'était dans
étonnant et drôle
exactement regardez on l'a il faisait
c'est un jeune comique qui va nous faire
un skate sur la
colonne
c'est pas fini c'est pas fini ce bordel
vous avez quel âge
ouais 8 ans je saigne soyez pas insolent
qu'est-ce qu'il y a tu as pourquoi tu
pleures mais il va te les rendre tes
bouquins et arrêter de jurer comme ça
mais vous faites chier bon Fabien
rends-lui sa BD sur New Look on en parle
plus
c'est toi qui a fait l'Australie
mais tu as quel âge
22 ans
je sais pas pourquoi mais plus je vous
regarde plus j'aime la pilule de ma
femme
[Rires]
moi je vais vous dire votre âge moi
votre âge moi j'étais
j'étais
comme vous j'étais comme vous
[Applaudissements]
non
et après j'aurais fini dans ce cas ça
j'ai construit un petit théâtre et
j'aurais permis de faire trois trois
sketchs en trois parties plus un truc à
la fin donc ça les a fait bouffer déjà
parce que contrairement à toi moi je
paye bien les gens qui viennent
alors d'ailleurs alors je t'explique
alors je te le dis j'ai beaucoup changé
maintenant je ne paye plus du tout
pendant un an pendant plus d'un an et
puis surtout on leur a dit quartier
libre amusez-vous éclatez-vous les mecs